- big shocker Steve Bannon is out at
Breitbart
and Anthony scare Moochie maybe back at
the White House joining us now from New
York I wish he was here
meet Anthony Anthony scare emoji hey
Anthony how you doing good happy new
year congratulations on your
unbelievable show Laura God thank you
you gotta come on more you gotta come on
more I'm thrilled to be here let's make
this not the last time how's that
fantastic let's let's talk about you in
the White House I'm reading all these
stories and reports that you talk to the
president regularly he has an enormous
amount of respect and affection for you
though there's there's some desire to
bring you back in the White House is
kind of a coy about it
see okay so I that's all news to me I
have not heard any of that and so I sort
of addressed that on Howie show over the
weekend I sort of think it's a little
bit of nonsense
I've not for a presumptuous person I
don't expect to go back to the White
House I certainly said on the air I
didn't think general Kelly would want to
hire me back although I think he's doing
a great job by the way I just think that
at the end of the day they seem to be
doing a great job
I thought today's communication strategy
was absolutely brilliant so my hat's off
to them for allowing the American people
to see the president Laura the way you
know the president the way I know the
president and his extreme quote unquote
presidential nature which you saw today
for 45 or 46 minutes so I love how the
left keeps saying he is mentally
unstable these are so desperate to try
to discount his successes and
accomplishments they are getting and
it's what's funny about this is that
they're the ones becoming more and more
unhinged and I think mentally something
I don't say unstable but I don't I don't
want to I don't want to give them a lot
of advice on your unbelievably popular
well rated show because I know that
they're listening but if the advice I
would give them is you should sort of
stop that because you're playing right
into the president's hands he wants you
to go fully off the rails he wants you
to go crazy on him every single day at
night because she looks so disingenuous
and you look so emotionally involved in
it to the point where you've lost your
objectivity completely and so that's
part of the whole derangement syndrome
that goes on
and the president surely stoking that
describing himself as a stable genius I
I thought that was terrific I've added
that to my vernacular now although my
family members view me as an unstable no
no but my point my point is is that at
the end of the day he's doing a great
job you know it I know he's doing a
great job I think I think the Democrats
tonight are going back to their
boardrooms wherever they go and they're
looking at each other said okay this is
a problem for us the guy looks
unbelievably presidential today and
tonight you were on CNN and you said
something I was watching you you said
something interesting let's watch okay
to really understand the president you
know there's a nuance of him there as
well he is a globalist by Nature
he wants to be part of the world order
okay global is by nature part of the
world order now I hear that and I think
of the speech he gave not so long ago I
think it was at the UN let's listen
watch both our friends and our enemies
put their countries above ours and we
while being fair to them must start
doing the same we will no longer
surrender this country or its people to
the false song of globalism okay which
is the real president Trump you see he
said he's against a globalist approach
to Reuters and for American sovereignty
okay so I got cut off a little bit over
the air and so let me finish it over
here what I was basically trying to say
is that there's a duality the president
he has a globalist streak in his
personality where he wants to be part of
the world order or he wants to give
speeches at the UN he's going to Davos
in two weeks he recognizes that the
international system can lead the global
priests and Prosperity at the same time
superseding all of that is his America
first strategy and taking care of the
American worker American businesses
American families infrastructure and etc
he gave an interview with the Financial
Times about five or six months ago Laura
where he basically explained that
duality and his personality and so I was
trying to get that out over there
thank you for letting me get it out over
here but I would say he's a he's a u.s.
person first America first but I do
think as evidenced by what he's doing in
two weeks and his UN speeches that he
does want to participate in the global
community in isolation of course he's
not an isolationist but my point is he
has specifically campaigned against the
philosophy of globalism because
globalism is a philosophy that kind of
erases national borders national
cultures and national identity strands
to a global order when I hear global
order I hear you know watch your freedom
watch our independence but I get that's
a that's of an Ag that's a vernacular
now it's sort of twisted that barbed
wire when I talk about the global order
I talk about what you're our allies the
strength of our allies hand checking
hard our adversaries not Obama's not Oh
God global ISM going back to like a
Kissinger / Dean a consent approach to
keeping the peace
I do you have 71 years of peace so let's
keep that for sure great to see you